die ausgeklügelte spieler
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer nächtlichen
runde vier gewinnt bzw eigentlich denkt
er jetzt gerade das gerade freestyle ist
allerdings wollten sie mich gestern auf
nehmen wir dieses video gerade seht
allerdings habe ich tatsächlich
eineinhalb stunden dafür gebraucht mir
meinen ist ordnet zurecht zu werke und
danach wann immer noch motzing wenig
vorhanden oder dupliziert oder doppelt
da oder irgend sowas ist ganz ganz
kompliziert deswegen haben wir ja ich
bin dumm das ist eigentlich die logische
schlussfolgerung aus dem ganzen
allerdings als tatsache jetzt jedenfalls
dass ich ein bisschen brauchen das
wieder hinzukriegen ich krieg jetzt auch
wenn ihr das video seht heute oder
morgen ist endlich mein pc mit passendem
lift und passende bildschirm dar
und dann kann ich auch endlich
vernünftig aufnehmen und mit
vernünftigem fließen ganz nord mehr
kümmern
und ich würde einfach sagen das sieht
man dich freitag aufnehmen also heute
ist er gerade mit verwenden das video
seht am freitag auf und dann kriegt ihr
samstag die nächste folge vize tief
samstagabend 19 uhr
und wir haben gedacht jetzt
entschädigung machen vier gewinnst du
kannst armselig natürlich erklärte vize
pitsch truppe spielt darf nicht so viel
reden also müsste es gleich sagen dass
ich die ganzen wort wegnehmen er muss
sehr leise sein weil die über mieterin
kunden oder easy abi freundin und neben
im nebenzimmer stift die mama musste
arbeit und oben drüber steht die
kriterien muss zum abi morgan das heißt
ich muss ganz okay wenn so lange braucht
sein dass wir jetzt nicht mehr richtig
aufnehmen könnt es tut mir sehr leid ich
bin so blöd naja egal also vier gewinnt
ist einfach so man muss wenn ich jetzt
zum beispiel 7 und guck mal wenn ich
jetzt zum beispiel hier drücken also ich
drücke zähle ich wenn ich jetzt hier
drücke dann kommt hier ein sand blog
unter das ist meine farbe
das ist meins das ist sand dann hab ich
hier 1 wenn du es zum beispiel drückst
du drückst hier zum beispiel da hinten
bei den schaltern der hierfür zuständig
ist dann kommt hier ein kies runter das
ist ein blog dann drück ich zum beispiel
wieder hier habe ich hier wieder in st
das ziel des spiels ist dass man vier
teile senkrecht oder waagerecht zusammen
kriegt man sich nebeneinander oder
diagonal ist nicht etwa eine stunde
ich mache das texture pack 1 für ich
mich ganz vergessen na ja das sollte
vielleicht auch noch dass ich glaube
dann sehen doch alles ein bisschen
besser erwartet so jetzt hab ich da drin
bist nix anders weil gibson ist die
fahrt müssten die fans nicht viel anders
sah dies anders
grafik anscheinend speck ich hab zwar
nicht viel anders
naja probier's mal schnell egal
eigentlich bin ich finde sehr zu seinem
grab wirklich relativ leise sein weiß
viertel vor elf ist mitten in der woche
meine eltern kennen und bei ihm die
schreiben halt ab und müssen zur arbeit
und naja ok ok gut ich würde sagen ich
fange jetzt mal hier ein in das ist ich
habe jetzt farbe hieß es musste wieder
hinsetzen wahrscheinlich ich mach dich
fertig bis merkel
da ist doch gar keine das heute ja du
bist ja ich leider sah
gibt es echt blöd ich habe jetzt schon
gewonnen ausgeklügelter spieler du ein
im anbetracht dessen dass das jetzt
hätte keine wirklichen darf ich muss
jetzt auch hier einsetzen dass wenn ich
noch nicht gewinnen können wäre das wenn
das im interesse des wäre das wenn ich
wirklich den strip wurde am
neujahrsmorgen das er geschrieben und
das verliere allerdings warte ich
doppelt weiter drücken will ich wirklich
einfach mal sagen würde ich einfach mal
sagen gibt ihre wochen später wenn ihr
möchtet gibt es eine revanche aufwand
konnte diese woche gewonnen weil ich
einfach richtig schlecht bin ich bin
wieder glauben also ich hab hier richtig
gefällt ich habe dir einfach die
billigsten taktik überhaupt lachen das
nicht okay aber ich würde sagen wenn es
sich gefallen lassen politischen und
also viel zu bieten am samstag wieder
ins klappt ja und ansonsten gibt's ja
heute früh bei mir ist vom himmel fällt
vom himmel wo bist du ich fall vom
himmel hauptgängen du bist ein engel ist
ein ende
ok ja gut dann wisst ihr bescheid heute
schreiben kommentare ich bin tag noch
ich hab die billigste als billig spiel
verloren man schreibt siegeszug an die
enz wieder und schreibt er ist der ba
ich bin der barbar okay dann will ich
sagen sie muss bei der nächsten folge
vize biest oder irgendwann früher wenn
ihr wollt dann noch mal dass sie
anständig spielen sollen dann schreibt
ihr konterspiel wir das nochmal
anschauen wenn es euch gefallen positive
bewertungen mit dem vermissten mann